Donald Trump in hot water again this
time for reportedly telling a story
about trying to pick up John Travolta's
wife at Kelly Preston in a tribute he
wrote about the couple's late son jet
who had died four days earlier in the
apparent since deleted tribute posed
unearthed by Mother Jones Trump
expressed his condolences for the
grieving family
but first recounts a night at a club in
the early 90s with Kelly Preston when he
quote worked like hell to try and pick
her up she was beautiful personable and
definitely had allure at the time I had
no idea she was married to John Travolta
Trump continued to praise Preston for
rejecting him which he claimed to be
impressive since his track record on
this subject has always been outstanding
this is just the latest in a string of
controversies for Trump the forefront
being the vulgar comments he made in a
2005 hot light conversation with Billy
Bush of Access Hollywood and in 1992
et's cameras caught Trump making lewd
jokes toward a group of young girls
you